I come to this video playing lmll em
what lmll em okay from the US and ok I
played him three times with three wins
so I'm not sure if you remembers but may
be out for revenge the carol can turn
off let's see it's more like a line that
I play I is playing the line that I
actually advocated to to play ass black
ok ok let's try that one this was
recently played against me and at first
I played the wrong reaction with Bishop
f5 after that I was in really deep
trouble Bishop g4 is better after Bishop
g4 I think if there should be three
years right maybe
we should be 4 D 5 is bad do 2nite be
five so what is the best okay this is
something else it's a complicated
position really early so Queen d2 on
okay most likely five always very tricky
like let's say try to fight for example
a five I will tear i take it not a good
move i guess but let's say i take it
Bishop before it's all coming with
temple so the whole line is really
interesting not sure about the queen bee
six Queen d2 moves both both of them I
think when I looked at this I figured
that on move aight queen bee six instead
Bishop g4 was good but ok when I was
examining it I was content to have one
good move and I didn't look like if
there is a good alternative maybe Queen
B 6 is also good so this happening here
next move yeah he also might play Bishop
g4 something like that i will play
Bishop e3 I guess yeah but wait a moment
there should be three he might take it
two and play five I would have seen five
I have c5 anyway in this position is
this in fact an idea they can click we
be foyer okay not too not too great a
great idea I can play d5 though 95 there
is no Knight d4 Knight c3 let's do that
very it's a very um tactical and tricky
position early on where you can easily
easily spoil the whole thing with one or
two substandard moves okay this I didn't
expect is it what is it is threatening
anything the sugar for looks good unlike
just attacking here and getting getting
developed then that the night probably
has to lose and let's say 93 I'll just
get castle what whoo I'm totally stunned
yeah i mean i understand the point but i
come i didn't think about that at all
okay the rookie em but there is night b5
and and moves like like that or c5c five
intending Bishop b5 check isn't this
like a very strong attack yeah okay
let's let's play it and do not overstep
the time I cannot save the rook anyway
okay
5p should be three I don't mind that so
much and have this check check first
maybe our chats give the check first and
then we should be three there should be
three ok Queen g1 now so I better get
the King out us out of that and now
let's see how am I going to go into play
this attack now there will be more than
one good ways to do it pretty sure d 625
is an idea go into a 5 would be
excellent also see sexy six would be
great see sixth exhibition checks now or
this d6 move d6 Bishop takes Queen d5
I can go back with the bishop who came
this isn't stronger than I thought I'm
threatening to he cannot really take
here because I take with the pawn as
well that's opening up the position
tremendously here after the capture that
just bishops in 6m Bishop 87 m I can do
whatever you want can take the one so
light weights and I just go here and
take Bishop a7 next
and that's not be five with Queen a for
coming I really have no idea i mean am
lots of material down but i'm only
looking at the takia
and with 50 seconds I mean I cannot
seriously calculate many things he has
III Quincy to hear maybe now doing
something others cheeky assess idea
yeah that is that's obviously not a deal
I can give Bishop e3 chicken yeah that
makes it Jez I mean this this was no in
no way playable for like no way ah ok
white resigns yeah ok that's it's a bit
of a shame because whitey is totally
winning that's pretty clear ok let's
let's start I mean there are many many
ways probably but ok 92 is the first one
plus four here here it's not it's not
totally clear I should probably just
play a normal movie amay be this is the
way to go just play Bishop e2 and the
tech with not being so much material
down even this is totally winning
according to the to the engine and this
is maybe too much young it's still
dangerous quindi one is still good for
white even with everything down material
wise it's just a super strong attack so
might be five Queen a form if you if you
give the engine engine some seconds it
gets higher and higher and once the
tickets should simply devastating and he
should be ADA swinging totally winning
ya b3 worst was was utter crap but you
know what I forgot about that after this
check yet I can really just go here I
never could go to see two because of e
to check but after he gives this check
of all I can't just go with them
yeah just an idiotic play b3 was totally
idiotic but I saw that it as a really
thought he is threatening Quincy one
with the made almost that's a very very
strange hallucination I can just take
this and over yeah this pawn should
should count for something yeah some
games are just I just like it totally
brain dead okay yeah thanks for watching